I think that that idea of sexual
disenchantment is bad for everyone but
it's really bad for women partly because
of physical imbalance between the Sexes
so the fact that it's only women who get
pregnant women have to suffer the side
effects of hormonal contraception women
are much smaller and weaker than men
which means that any heterosexual
encounter if you've got a man and woman
Alone Together the woman's going to be
almost always the more physically
vulnerable party so there's that kind of
risk inherent to sexual encounters that
women experience that men can't
experience in the same way there's Al to
the psychological stuff and that's more
controversial because the push towards
kind of radical equality within feminism
in Liberal feminism has also included
pushing back very hard against the idea
that there are any innate differences
between the Sexes on a psychological
level